on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV he's an
Entertainer an
artist the star of a oneman
show the stage is always his he calls
himself a lion sometimes he calls
himself the goat well now the biggest
ego in World sport meets well a
similarly proport
ego on Center Stage it's Zlatan
Ibrahimovic
[Music]
uncensored slatan how are you I'm good
thank you I can't think of anybody
better suited to do an interview for a
show called Pi Morgan uncensored than
you I think I'm the perfect guy for
you do you feel like like you've always
been
uncensored I feel
uh yeah I feel I've been myself always
even if people think I try to act or
something but I think I look I see and I
say so wrong and right I'm being myself
I think it's very important will I get
to the real you in this interview 100%
you put the
level youve just retired yes something I
don't think you probably thought would
ever happen you worried about it
happening you were concerned about it
happening what's the reality been like
I'm I just retired three months ago and
uh I agree with you that if I wanted or
or not is different but I accepted it
because in the end I was not feeling
good I could have continued I could have
continued suffering in physical way and
uh keep going but I wanted to feel good
good and I didn't want to have a
consequence after my career where I'm
limping or I cannot do things with my
boys so I chose to to stop and I think I
stopped in the right moment but to be
honest with you when I see all the other
Strikers out there I could still play
because I I would do much more than them
and better than them and that's not for
my ego that's fact you want to name some
names I could give you many names
probably 95% of them out there so you
think you're better than 95% even now I
am better I don't
think i' take you Aral I would take your
Aral okay could be could be I had a
chance to go there but I know you we're
going to come to that it breaks my heart
can't I can't even think about it um
we're at the sharby theater one of
London's great theaters here you're used
to being on the big stage this is one of
the big stages of theater it's an empty
crowd there's no one here few people you
should have brought me the crowd because
well I wanted to see I I would make them
bounce you would you would 100% how are
you going to deal with not having the
big crowds being on the big stage with a
big crowd and now now
this I think I don't need that I I've
I've been doing it for 20 years 25 years
I played in front of
90,000 and uh I made him bounce I made
him chair I made him whistle I made him
hate I made him love so all these things
and uh I don't have that ego that I need
attention now because I am who I
am I'm remembered for what I did on the
field
so I'm not looking for attention I'm not
looking for get recognized and uh and
all those things because or else I would
choose to be a commentator I would do
those things that you have these ex
players doing
because they're doing it because they
still miss the attention they want to be
seeing in fromont front of the camera
and what do you want to do have you
worked it out yet I'm a little bit
curious about the acting thing
because I've been trying some things in
front of the camera I mean I'm not shy
if I'm a good actor I don't know I don't
think I can see you playing a James Bond
villain villain yes yes I would smash
James Bond but he could win in the end
I'm okay with that but during the movie
I would smash him and then and then
probably I would lay
somewhere 2 m under ground which is okay
cuz I feel with you Zlatan that your
whole life has been a fight yes and
that's the way you've actually liked it
you were brought up in a in an
environment like that you played
football in that environment you were at
your best when you were in a scrap I
think he's a correct picture of me
because even if I'm not in a fight I'm
looking for a fight
because it's something that kicks I get
a kickoff I get adrenaline enough and
where I came from it was about survival
mode I mean the the strongest guy would
survive and uh and all around me was
they were talking like it always ISS
media they criticize you they talk about
you and uh and they they want to have
something to say but that was me if I
would would not be like that I would not
be where I came or maybe sit here and
speak to Pierce Morgan so will I get a
better interview out of you by being
nice to you or if I start
yanking your chain insulting you a bit
roughing you up a bit but I get the real
Zlatan then no you get you will get the
real zatan in any any question I mean if
you're looking for something I will give
it to you I cannot change me I'm not
here to to be beautiful or uh or to be
perfect to somebody I think being
yourself is perfect authenticity has a
power to it I think I think so yes and
me getting angry and that that's me I
need I need to get fired up so that's
how I bring out sharpness that's how I
bring out the best out of me when I walk
on fire because if you make me feel too
comfortable I'm playing to win and to
win I will destroy you I think to
understand why you're like this I want
to take you back to to Malmo uh to
Rosengard where you grew up you've
described it as being like a ghetto it
was a rough tough place you said you can
take a guy away from Rosen
but you can't take Rosen God out of a
guy yeah what do you mean by that I mean
I can go I can come I can make it out of
the ghetto but the ghetto will stay in
me so I came from Rosengard
because I am still who I am even if I'm
not there and that's what I say you you
can take yourself out of a place but the
the place you
were raised and and and born in it will
still be still be in you so
that I would never change for success I
would never change for whatever happens
to me tell me about your parents um your
father first of all sephi he was a
caretaker yeah um I was interested that
he he suffered quite a lot of Torment as
a result of the war in
Yugoslavia um it affected him quite
deeply I think have you ever had a
chance to really talk about that with
him no because he never spoke about it
with me I was living alone with my with
my father and in the beginning was okay
because I mean the father he did every
my father did everything to to survive
to to bring in money to to pay the bill
to pay the rent to make me feel happy he
did his maximum and the best out of the
conditions that was there and then the
war started
started then he was more distance from
me because he kept everything away from
me and uh and he took it very hard
because I remember like it's no secret
that my father was
he drink and he was sitting there with
his
phone try to reach out for the family
members I don't know what was going on
because I was pretty small at that time
and but but I could see and often what
you see stays longer than what you hear
so but we never discussed about it he
never put me in between I was young and
I was crazy I was wild I was out I was
playing football a lot I still had the
discipline to go to school because if I
would not go to school my my father
would smash me which
is which is normal in our world so how
would he do that no he would he would
become aggressive he would he would make
sure I do it he would not hit me my
mother would hit me she was the one
hitting not my father my father I read
that your mother used a wooden spoon
wooden spoon and hit me so when that
would break she would say to me go buy a
new one but I didn't break it you broke
it but was still by fault how many
spoons did you have to buy a lot a lot a
lot then it came to a certain moment
like how do you call the thing you put
when you press the bread like the round
when she came with that run away yeah
yeah then I run away I said this is too
hard this you cannot touch me with but
for us was normal for us was normal I
understand but it there'll be people
watching this who have not experienced
that from their parents do you feel that
you carried mental scars from from no
being hit or not no it made me stronger
It Made Me Stronger because now when I'm
a parent myself I understood what my
parents went
through and
uh and it's not easy what's your
relationship like with your parents
today I'm closer with my mother with my
father it's it's it has been like it was
before not so close as my mother because
it's two big egos to I am my father so
when he fights me he fights himself
which he doesn't understand because I am
like him he made me who I am what been
do you think the proudest he's ever felt
for you in your career he will not show
it what about your mother you have a
better relationship with her a closer
one with her closer how's her life now
what have you been able to do for her I
mean you bought her a lovely home I
think didn't you about a lot of stuff
which is normal you tried to help out
what
understood fast quick in my in my life
when I became successful was I will help
you but I will not interfere in your
private life so when I was I grew up I
had an empty fridge which is not a
secret I always make sure they have a
full fridge because that when I mov
together with my with my Helena I said
listen the only demands I have from you
that the fridge has to be full because
every time I open the fridge I want it
to be full even if I will not take some
something out I just want to take away
that image where it's empty and I have
milk I have cheese I have a ham and
nothing more and I want to take out that
image from my ra when I was raised and I
have a full fridge even if I would not
pick up something did you feel as you
grew up that you had love from your
parents even if they had a strange way
of showing
it I think we show love in a different
way in my family we show love by
aggression we show love in a hard way we
are not the ones we clap you on the back
we hug you we we hold you around that is
not the way we show love we have a more
rough
environment you were bullied when you
were young you said I was a small guy I
had a big nose I had a lisp I had speech
therapy you could have I guess like a
lot of people in that world he could
have just continued down a life of crime
maybe ended up in prison or Worse dead
do you think about that that Crossroads
in your life the football gave you the
way out I think football it
it it rescued me because obviously where
I came from there is right side no you
go right side or you go left side and
you choose what you want I always played
football because my mental where I came
from we played football we played
football and the mentality was I'm the
best is uncensored the rest so
that was my mentality and my my
motto good evening I'm Pi Morgan
uncensored in New York City King pi and
King Q I think there's only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying he's
mocked your weight Trump yeah look at
him fail not working just cuz they're
skin folk don't mean they're kin folk do
you believe you can win this War making
me cry again they're trying to force you
out yes I feel betray keep it award
winning Lucy leby will die behind bars
and a senior Doctor Who first raised
concerns about Ley once NHS manages to
be regulated we needed answers a lot
sooner this is what 7 years down the
line I mean it's completely ludicrous he
was clearly something of the face of the
ward so even more Unthinkable if this
nurse had misgendered somebody on a
board she' have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories weighty Katy that would make her
a better princess of wealth cuz you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people gay Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I he
wish I'd never met him the conservative
party can certainly win the next
election can we lab 29 in the can we did
he say yes I have taken drugs and they
bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
then needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
Rest their
souls Let It
Roll y yes if we stopped producing oil
the knock on effect is far larger than
just CO2 I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know now you're
probably going to boot me off
show some of them they're easily
lit you can kiss my American
ass thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you there a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has been telling
the truth you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
by if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
is about you and your opinions if you're
thinking about it we're talking about
it it's all about me that a
[Music]
joke you said that the two most
important people in your life uh one was
your great friend a longtime agent Amina
riola who died last year yes that must
have been a huge blow to I I lost my
agent several years ago suddenly in his
50s same thing and he was the one of my
closest friends knew everything about me
I mean it's a very unique relationship
you have what what impact did his death
have on you it was a big loss it's still
a big loss and uh and I still miss him
today and uh and I will miss him forever
because he was not only agent for me he
was everything my career started when I
I moved to a but my real career started
with when the first day I met him and uh
and we did everything together the
football outside football I shared every
moment with him happy moments bad
moments and uh and even in my private
life I would present
him a girl and I would say what do you
think it's for me or not he would say
yes or no so he was involved in
everything I did but but really
everything and uh and when that tragic
moment happened to me last year I
was it was not the same thing football
became different for me and and in
everything I do
because everything we did was was
sharing moments obviously I became older
he saw me grow from a baby to a man I
became who I am because of him also and
uh and we would challenge each other all
the time he would give me so much I
would give him so much so he would
always trigger me like that so I took it
very hard and my game would not be the
same because I'm doing things now on my
own not the with somebody which I would
always do because before I do something
I would call him what do you think so
this interview would be Min know what do
you think and he would say he would say
yeah go destroy him or go make him
famous we would disc this guy he would
give which one are you going to do here
no I'll make you I don't know you're
you're big shot so I'm not worried about
you when it happened was a big loss
because he was like like a role model
for me Father
friend agent
example and
uh yeah I learned a lot about from him
so like I said I still miss him we all
miss
him the other you would enjoy with him I
you never knew him I met him once very
briefly this interview uncensored you
would he was a great character and a
brilliant agent everyone knew that and
I'm very sorry for you that you lost
such a close friend um the other person
you said was the most important of
course is your partner Helena uh she was
an economics graduate uh she was a
successful former children's television
presenter 11 years older than you and
you meet uh at Malmo train station
outside of Bureau des and her first
impression wasn't great slat no you were
20 she thought you were pretty rude
pretty cocky a bit of a a bit of a Yobo
you turned around how did you manage to
convince her you want her worst
fears I mean I didn't give up because I
saw this blonde blonde girl and I was in
my in my Ferrari I wanted to act cool be
cool but she had a pretty cool car also
so and I parked the car and I was like
listen try to be cool and she saw me she
was ignoring me totally and I was like
that was not the response I wanted to
have and uh and I was shy when I was
young I was shy because I wasn't
feeling I wasn't feeling the guy I am
today let's say but she was 10 years
older than me 11 years older so I was a
little child for her I was like
unmature little for her so she was this
elegant moving around good knew what she
was doing knew what she want I different
way of showing my love I had a different
temperament and uh but she had a lot of
patient and I think because of the age
she's still there today
because she being more mature than me
and having
patient or she or she saw an investment
in me oh maybe she might want have seen
she saw the future she might have seen a
better you down the line right I mean
you said she understands my character
and accepts I'm a bit crazy I was
surrounded by chaos when we met I was
out of control I'm calmer today maybe
she realized she could calm the Beast
could be could be I mean like I said the
age I think made a difference because
and then you get to know each other
obviously I think a partner every five
year change I don't think you're with
your wife you have the same wife like
the first day you met her is not the
same you don't actually have a wife
that's you never actually CU I don't
want to lose
50% you have two children I don't have
you have two two children I have two
boys I think why why have you never
asked her to marry you or have you
H I have and what happened she said no
really yes so she's strong yeah when was
this this was a couple of years ago
because I said after 20 years you
deserve to be married with me she said I
don't I don't need to be married with
you to be with you she's strong she's
very strong how did you feel about being
rejected I think it's cool because if
you do that you you gain more respect
for me cuz I don't have to win all the
time are you going to keep
trying no she had one chance she will
not get a second chance but she has two
boys from me so that's even bigger than
being married and to be honest I don't
need a piece of paper to to show that
she's mine she She's Mine whatever paper
we we have be among us would you want
your boys to play Elite level football
having been through all the ups and
downs you've been through yeah yeah why
not they choose themselves I mean
they're playing football today they play
for Milan and uh they do they're very
focused and and the important thing they
don't do it for me because I see a lot
of parents now when I have boys I bring
them to the game football but also
different kind of sports I see they push
their kids how do you give them the
hunger that you had I treat them like
they would be my teammates I don't treat
them like they're my boys if that is
okay or not I don't know but I treat
them like they would be my teammates I'm
direct to them they have to be happy
healthy but with disciplined they have
to do the things because my philosophy
is why be normal when you can be the
best your talent has made you extremely
wealthy do you know how rich you
are I always say money is not important
you agree with me or not money is
important I'll tell you why no not
having a lot of money wait wait a lot of
money is important I think removing no
no I think I would say that removing the
worry about not having money is
important in other words the stress that
many people feel from not having enough
money just to get by I think that is a
terrible stress so having enough money
where you have security and comfort in
your life I don't think you need to have
gazillions money creates problems even
in families money brings stress the more
you have the more stress and and where
is the stop you could live a good life
with normal money but what is normal
money now I've been on the both sides
I've been without money grew up with a
family where my father made, EUR in
pound I don't know how much it is and
still we had a good at that thousand
over what period monthly monthly monthly
thousand then you pay bills and that I
don't know how much is left and uh and
we have to share it not share it it was
his he gave me whenever I needed and
but I had a good life I had it good at
that moment so were you happier where is
the stop were you happier then but what
is happiness well you tell me it's
moments I'm happy now in 10 minutes I
could be unhappy so it's moments uh
money makes it easier makes your life
easier but I don't think it gives you
happiness because for me happiness is
moments you're happy with one situation
now my dream was come to Barcelona after
one year was my nightmare yeah so it
moments but I agree with you but you
must have had a big offer to go to
Saudi I had an offer also from China I
had offer also from uh from from Saudi
but the situation is what do you want
what is
your what objectives do you have I said
before we started like certain players
need to
finish his career in big stage because
that is like the high end of your career
because you have to be remembered for
your talent not for what you earned
because if you be remembered in opposite
way what we are training every day for
what we are being recognized for is our
talent and that's what you want to be
remembered for so I think certain
players that reach a certain level they
have to stop in a certain stage and
that's the big stage you cannot go in a
lower stage and and finish your career
in a different way but some players
needed the the situations where you can
earn a lot of money because they didn't
earn enough how much have you turned
down to play in Saudi I mean in
Saudi no I had a bigger offer in China I
had 100 million offer in China but I and
I went to America because I got injured
and the situation changed but I turned
it down before I went there
because it's not what I wanted and I
would instead of getting a lot of money
straight I
would I would challenge myself to arrive
there by different different ways of
coming to
there but the challenge to get it not
because I need it or because I want it
would you have any moral problem in
playing in Saudi Arabia no no what would
no absolutely not I mean you have the
golf situation now they they came
together and they made it made it one so
I'm just sorry for the players that
didn't go before because they didn't get
the money that the players got it so no
the football listen wherever you play
football it's football football connects
people like it's a dream we share both
of us you were a fan you were not a
professional you're an Arsenal fan and I
feel sorry for you a little bit but as a
professional football player as long as
you play football and and Saudi is
growing MLS is growing I mean China had
a peak and then I don't know this the
situation changed there but a moral
thing no no we are still I mean we do
things for ourself and our our family
who would judge you in 5 10 years when
you have a healthy wealthy healthy life
and have a good life that's the
difference if you were to fall over dead
tomorrow how much would you be worth I
don't know I don't probably half half a
billion yeah half a billion US Dollars
yeah but it's not important for me
because I don't care about it because if
I die tomorrow what what Whats no no I
understand you but I'm thinking Next
Step it's not important my did the kid
in Malmo on those rough Streets Could
you ever have imagined no ever that one
day you'd be worth half a billion
dollars
no
[Applause]
[Music]
this is talk
TV
you talked earlier about having this
dream of playing for Barcelona and it
did turn out to be a nightmare and
probably the main reason for that was
the breakdown in your relationship with
the manager Pep Guardiola who right now
many would say is the best coach in the
world you had a very different
experience with him uh you called him a
coward with no balls uh you said when
you buy me you're buying a Ferrari if
you drive a Ferrari you put premium
Petrol in a tank you hit the motorway
and you step on the G Guardiola filled
up with diesel and took a spin in the
countryside he should have bought a
Fiat I think Guardiola is an amazing
coach when I was there the coaching was
different compared to what I had before
he totally on a different level that's
why he's successful because if you see
on his
career if you take the last 15 10 to 15
years the guy never came third place
he's always first or second so the coach
is amazing and uh but I had a different
situation with him because I had the
coach and I get to meet the person and
we it became a problem a problem I I was
not aware of because I solve my problems
I look in the eyes doesn't mean I have
to like you or dislike you we will solve
it and it takes one second to solve it
we go straight and we solve it but solve
a problem if the problem is between two
persons it takes two to to solve it and
especially when the other side doesn't
know and I remember when I was there I
was like because before I came to
Barcelona always media have their input
and saying they would go like you don't
fit in here you don't fit in the culture
it's different different because who I
was and my mistake was there I tried to
fit in instead of being who I am first
six months was okay everything was good
no but the strange thing the first
meeting I had with him was like remember
players here don't don't come with
Ferrari Porche and that then it it felt
like why he was already judging you but
why you call me every day to bring me
here and then you want to send this
message to me don't worry I will not
bring my car and I didn't bring it
didn't bring it for six seven eight
months and then I started
to the directors because I I would
perform bad and the the people above him
would complain but said we cannot engage
if you don't open the door so I would
have to go to him and say listen what's
going on I think with the situation with
Messi putting him I need more space you
brought me in so I need my space to do
my thing because the way you want me to
play now is not I'm not good enough then
better you put the other players so I
was direct and open and we spoke
normal normal conversation because I
never had a problem with a coach in a
Prof professional way and he said in the
end which was cool don't worry I take
care of this I was like okay cool
everything is done next game I'm I'm on
the bench said okay no problem and I'm
not the type that would go to the coach
why am I not play why am I not playing
you should play me second game
bench third game bench said okay and now
I'm getting pumped up because obviously
I need to do more to show
myself but I noticed it was not about me
performing anymore it was I think my
opinion he felt offended for me saying
to him I needed more space and the way I
wanted to to play he's punishing which
is okay yeah which is okay he's the
coach bad results he leaves player stays
and I respect that but be open to me be
direct to me so we understand each
other fourth game bench and then I
started to make noise because it's not
okay for me anymore now I'm on the bench
and I have on the I'm on the bench
because of a s situation I created not
by my own H how do you say by my own
choice because of the people above him
because for them I was a big
investment and the fourth game I bring
my Ferrari and I bring the hands of
Ferrari and I knew it would create
another situation so I parked the car in
front of his office so you with me I
with you that was my motto you parked it
in front of his office in front of his
office I said this
is you want to play with fire I'll bring
you fire but I will burn you but
obviously he's the coach because what
punish most the players player if he
doesn't play because obviously you want
to play but the boss is the coach but in
that moment I understood this will not
be okay because there is something how
did he react to you parking your Ferrari
outside he would not say nothing to me
because he would avoid me is that why
you use the phrase cow but no balls yeah
because he would not confront his
whatever problem he had it came to a
head there a dressing room incident
after Bara lost inter uh and it's
alleged that you threw a training kit
box across the room yeah at guard is
that true versus him yeah did you hit
him no he didn't hit how did he how did
he react it was a message no he stepped
out of the lock room room he would not
confront me he would not confront me
like I see him because I follow football
I see him in the press conferences now
and that saying his thing
this didn't happen here so maybe
become bigger men if he's watching this
interview what would you say he would
say I still think about it still I I am
crying no I think he's amazing coach
don't get me wrong I think he's amazing
coach what he's doing he changed the
game 100% he's being very successful as
a man as a man I see him do some press
conference I see him has been stepping
up so he's not he's not the one I know I
mean that I met so I'm happy for him I
mean remember we share the same dream we
work I was a professional player he was
a professional player so I don't want
any harm for him dislike or
like still we we we share the same dream
I didn't know that's my still until
today I don't know what what the problem
was you think he should have the courage
to tell you no he shouldn't he should
run away
way one coach you loved was Jose
Mourinho and you had great success with
him what was it about Jose you you said
I think that Jose when he when he comes
in a room the lights go on whereas
Guardiola pulls the curtains yeah first
time Jose presented himself was when he
won the Champions League with the with
Porto and then he came to England and he
made a lot of noise but you walk like
you talk no he did everything he said he
would do and for me that triggers me
because that is not arrogance for me
that is not you think you're something
that for me is confidence he really
believes in it and and he's outspoken
and I'm and I'm the same I believe in
certain things and I will say it and I
will do everything to
reach to my objectives but the the thing
with Mourinho is he makes you
feel so strong that you go out and you
fight for him
and you do whatever it takes to win you
scored over 500 goals uh you played over
100 times your country and you're that
Sweden's top scorer what's your favorite
goal if I could relive a moment would it
be the bicycle kick against England yes
because it was England I tell you why
because of many reasons because the goal
is amazing I mean the goal for
me not because he me not because of my
ego who would do that thing I don't see
many players do that thing because many
players in that situation we were
winning 3-2 it was the last minutes
would take down the ball and waste time
because you want to win the game
obviously but when I saw the moment I
said heart was the goalie and I said I
will fool him now when I saw him run out
I will pretend to go forward towards him
then I will back off then I took it
instinctly from there like turn around
and as a striker you know where your
goal is you don't need to see the goal
you can put me in every angle on the
field I will know where the goal is
because so as soon as you hit the ball
with the bicycle kick you knew it was I
knew already where the goal was the
let's say and did you know when you hit
it it was going in yes you you said you
have stopped outside in the street by
some Paparazzi and asked was Cristiano
Ronaldo's bicycle kick goal the best
you've seen and you said yes do you
still think that I was being sarcastic
oh you were yes you meant you was not
many understood but I'm not there to
explain that because if you cannot read
my mind it's not my fault so you think
yours was better 100% 100% I said in an
interview later you should try it from
40 mters it's a big difference even if
his was beautiful but this was from 40
mters is it is it I've asked I actually
asked him the same question but when you
score a goal like that
is it better than
sex I mean my game that in that game was
crazy because why it was that's what I
wanted to come that's not the answer
yeah but you have to see the whole
package the goal no sex is better come
on my friend sex is better we don't even
go there sex is 10 times better not one
time better 100% is this in case Helena
is watching this no no no no no no no no
sex is better whoever thinks different
he has a problem with his sex life he
should get help but uh I wouldn't know I
never scored a 40 yard bicycle kick so
no you get a lot of adrenaline so after
the goal I saw Welbeck I think he was
the striker and I took off the shirt and
I said enjoy because something like this
he will never see again and he was
watching me so you see even in that
moment I get anger out instead of just
in Joy so I throw it out and I look at
him actually I was rude but I don't know
why I was rude to him I needed to find
OB so I said enjoy because you will
never enjoy this again but he hasn't
done nothing for me but that's me
looking for it's your natural fighting
Instinct so he's not personal against
him so that's me and he was watching me
he didn't understand nothing because I
have nothing happened but the game what
the goal is why the goal is most
beautiful because of
England because before I came to England
they talk bad because if you haven't
played in Premier League you're not good
enough that's the mentality here which I
respect because they want to see you
challenge your game here and then during
the game they they were calling me the
diva they were calling me a fake Carol
the fans are doing yeah the fans so it
was going on and before that the media
was writing I never score against
England teams in Champions League I
always fail against the english team so
everything this was going around my head
so that's why I say it's a whole package
I score four goals and I don't I think F
Baston or I have the record against
England and this was a whole package
because of all the I got that is the
most beautiful goal and is a goal
England will always remember for the
rest of their life that's true in the in
the list of alltime great footballers
where do you put yourself now I have to
speak as a fan because what are we
judged after what we win Collective what
we win individual I'm talking about
individual quality as players just the
skill without winning anything I think
I'm the
best without joking I'm the most
complete player that ever
exist skills and all this when we talk
pure only the player the abilities no I
think 100% no
joking see I I love that about you I
would love every Striker that's ever
played for Arsenal to have that
mentality yeah they had their chance
yeah that you have to discuss with vanar
I'm going to come to that I'm coming to
that okay okay let me ask you first of
all I no but I think it's not about
being arrogant and that I
think self-belief surely is confidence
backing yourself but also backing It Up
by I believe it listen I mean you love
Muhammad Ali right wait I will do
another example when I say I am God you
think I'm joking or not you tell me me
I'm not joking when I come on the field
I feel like that you feel like God I
feel like God when I'm on the field an
omnipotent power I feel Untouchable and
I feel I will smash everyone that comes
in my way that is a mental part let's
say boxing Tyson Fury is the champion if
you ask
me if I could smash I would say yes I
would I would Smash and in my head yes
but when I come in the ring he would
knock me out after two seconds but the
mentality is yes I can yes but in the
ring he would he would eat me alive
without doubts but my mentality is I
can good evening I'm Pi Morgan
uncensored in New York City King pi and
King Q I think there's only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying he's
mocked your weight Trump yeah look at
him fail St working just cuz they're
skin Folk don't mean they're kin folk do
you believe you can win this war is
making me cry again they're trying to
force you out yes I feel betray keep it
award
winning Lucy Ley will die behind bars
and a senior Doctor Who first raised
concerns about leby once NHS manages to
be regulated we needed answers a lot
sooner this is what 7 years down the
line I mean it's completely ludicrous he
was clearly something of the face of the
W so was even more Unthinkable if this
nurse had misgendered somebody on a
board she'd have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories weighty Katy that would make her
a better princess of wals cuz you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people gay
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time I he wish I'd never met
him the conservative party can certainly
win the next election can we yes lab 29
Points IM the
can did he say yes I have taken drugs
and they bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things the rest of the world has watched
on in sort of mounting horror as this
story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal the death toll from
the Titanic tragedy has risen to 1522
and may God rest your
souls
[Music]
Let It
Roll y yes if we stop producing oil the
knock on effect is far larger than just
CO2 I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to boot me off chart and
this some of them they're easily
LD you can kiss my American
Air thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you there a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has been telling
the truth you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned if it's on your mind it's on
talk TV it's about you you and your
opinions if you're thinking about it
we're talking about
it it's all about me that's a
[Music]
joke what do you make of what's
happening in Manchester United they were
the dominant team in the Premier League
for so many years under Sir Alex
Ferguson they've not been able to
replicate that and right now they're
really struggling what what do you put
it down to I remember when I came to
United and uh whoever I met there
everybody was talking about how Fergie
would do it
Ferguson this would not happen with
Ferguson this Ferguson would not do and
I was like listen I don't care what
happened before I'm here to do my own
story my own present time and be
remembered for what I did now not for
what he did something I respect that he
brought the club wherever he brought it
the club is because what he did but time
goes on but I think now in
United I don't know there's some kind of
how do you say demonstrations about the
owners to sell it and that but just a
reminder the owners are investing it's
not like they're not investing because
they they brought in many players for
high amount of money so tell I think
it's it's a little bit wrong wrong
saying that they're not doing what the
fans expect them to do then I don't know
what the real reason is behind
everything are the players
underperforming I think with the new
coach the new coach came from where he
was a a I was in Ajax also Ajax is a
talented Club they have the best talents
in the club they don't have big
stars what is the experience of this
coach young talents he comes to United
United is different mentality different
players so the players there supposed to
be big
stars so I think with his experience
being there I don't know if it talks for
him or not because he I think he's in a
different situation and then above him
there is a gap where he doesn't get the
help to manage the team listen this is
what I read in the paper so it's not I
have all the situation that that is
happening but I can just imagine him
coming from Ax to to United is a big
difference because I've been in both
clubs you manage talents upgrowing is
different kind of approach because there
you have a different kind of discipline
you come to United you you do the same
thing I don't know I don't believe and I
don't think it's the same treatment you
give I mean Cristiano Ronaldo when he
gave the interview to me when he left
United he said that he felt he didn't
have the respect of Eric ten hog you see
with Jaden Sancho now a similar
situation ten hog criticizing him in
public and so on maybe that is an
illustration of his of his problems in
managing big talent but I don't I don't
say it's the coach fault because
experience you cannot buy you just have
to get time to get the experience but
it's two different situation being in ax
being in United then if it's his fault I
don't think because I think everybody
has a responsible in the whole situation
we are a piece of puzle from the big
puzle so everybody have a responsibility
to do and to to fulfill the the the
demands United has to win the the they
have to win every title they play for
now they're being dominating by the
neighbors and uh and it's a totally
different situation there and uh you
need to find the right path again and to
to push for that is he do you think he's
out of his depth a bit ten
hog I think he needs more time to get
the experience how to handle a team but
you don't really get time at a club
likeit no obviously not because we need
to win that's the reality you come to my
when I was in Milan I cannot give you
time to to develop to to to perform you
need to perform straight because like I
said survival mode it's you or another
one because United is in a situation you
don't do good enough the next day there
is another one M and the result speaks
for itself so that's why that is tricky
but how much time do you give a coach I
don't know depends of the owners what
they want but if you listen to the fans
you don't have a lot of time because
they want to win absolutely and I
understand them because they're used to
win and they want to still win did you
feel when you were at United one of the
things Cristiano suggested to me was the
younger players didn't really show him
the respect he was expecting but respect
is nothing you ask for respect is
something you take so it depends on you
I have to make sure you respect me it's
nothing you ask for you don't ask the
young guys for respect you take the
respect and you put them in the place
so it's up to him to make sure they
respect you if it was me and he don't
respect me that young player is the last
thing he would have in his life cuz I
would make sure he respect me and he
would know it for the rest of his life
so it's up to him to make sure they
respect him you said about yourself I
can't help but laugh at how perfect I am
yeah you don't see
it is there any
perfect looking sharp I went to buy a
only for you you made you cost me €3,000
you know what it was worth it you're
looking sharp thank you thank you but is
there any
imperfection I mean I had moments where
criticize yourself what would you what
would you
choose I
mean for me the confidence is is
bulletproof I have a strong
confidence uh I would not
go and I have complex on myself and do
and say I need to fix this this
obviously I could do certain things but
I am who I am I cannot change that I was
created by my parents and I became and I
look the way I do
so for me that is perfection because I
cannot ch I have a big nose yeah I have
a big nose I have a space between blah
blah blah but that's who I am I cannot
change I don't want to change because
you should believe and in who you are
because you are perfect there's only one
thing you got
wrong oh no I'm telling you what it is
there's one thing you got wrong so it's
your birthday next week right will have
been just before the
show and there's one big mistake you
made in your I know already what you
will say what am I going to say because
I I didn't go to Arsenal yeah yes you
see first I predict future first of all
tell me why you didn't join AR when you
were 17 so when I was young I had a lot
of interest from a lot of clubs and one
of them was Arsenal so I came to the
office of Mr aren vaner and was was big
hype because I saw these players be Camp
HRI I saw Yung B I saw
Vieira I saw all these players and I was
like this is this is big because these
players I see in TV
even if I already played in high level
Sweden but this was big because this was
like I am here now last week I was
playing PlayStation with these guys and
I spoke with v and he has this French he
he was tall I didn't expect him to be so
tall I come in his office and we speak
and yeah and he was like what do you
want he wanted to get to know me to feel
me because I think he is a type of
person he just don't buy the play he
wants to know what he's buying I think
and yeah and then in the end he had
Arsenal shirt with number nine and uh he
want you to come and do a trial for two
weeks and from all this everything was
good until until he said you come and do
a trial and I was looking at him
obviously he's V I'm nobody in that
moment said don't do trials and he was
like what do you
mean I don't do trials either you want
me or you don't want me or else why am I
here like that was my but it was not to
play a game it was me no but you have to
come and do a trial and that no no you
don't understand I don't do trials and
that was it I didn't I never went to
Arsenal well and then I yeah this story
breaks my heart right cuz you would have
been fantastic at us you are exactly the
kind of Striker we need right now I can
tell you we would win a lot of trophies
I'm 100% true we would have won even
more tropy but I also know I can tell
from your face it's a big regret of
yours okay you wish if you had your time
again so this is your birthday present
okay thank it is uh Ibrahimovic wow nice
number 11 it looks good looks sharp I
think it's your size and you know what
it's never too late you can come out of
retirement thank you slip it on looks
good right thank you thank you very much
H was a great interview nice meeting you
a real
[Music]
pleasure
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]